et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec bernard ravenel historien
auteur de la résistance palestinienne
des armes à la non violence aux éditions
l'harmattan en direct donc sur ce
plateau par skype en direct de tel aviv
jacques benillouche journaliste
indépendant bonsoir règles ni douches
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france j'invite donc nos deux
invités à débattre à distance alors
donald trump on l'a dit qui a affiché un
optimisme sur la réussite de ce plan
hier est ce que vous partagez le même
optimisme ce soir après donc le
dévoilement de ce plan c'est vraiment
difficile
je crois qu'on assistait au
franchissement d'une ligne rouge
internationale qui était en quelque
sorte l'existence de la palestine telle
qu'elle était reconnu par les nations
unies un cas de la cisjordanie et de
gaza et pour lequel la frontière était
là là la ligne la ligne verte et pour
lequel finalement il y avait aucune
discussion concernant la légitimité de
cette ligne verte
aujourd'hui pousser mais en même temps
par évidemment le président netanyahu
il ya ce franchissement 11 jours on
assiste à une dernière étape peut-être
de la conquête de la palestine
historique
quelles qualités un moment envisagé par
le par le mouvement sioniste début du 20
siècle dont il ya quelque chose là un
événement historique je pense
extrêmement grave
jacques benillouche
votre analyse sur ce diagnostic de
bernard à venelles mais c'est un
diagnostic que je ne partage pas
beaucoup parce que d'abord ce que je
voulais dire c'est que ce plan n'a rien
de nouveau
nous avons perdu 52 ans parce que le 27
juillet 1967
le ministre du travail de l'époque ygal
allon ministre socialiste du
gouvernement les vieilles colts avaient
présenté exactement ce plan à quelques
et pilonnent près il a été rejeté
j'ai reçu tout à l'heure la carte que
nous a envoyé donald trump gelé mise
face à la carte de ygal allon et on se
retrouve exactement dans les mêmes
conditions
ça c'est un point factuel moi je vais me
positionner sur des points factuel je ne
suis pas un membre d'aucun parti
je suis journaliste j'analyse et donc je
me base sur des faits moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que là les
palestiniens ont raté plusieurs
occasions
plusieurs occasions à chaque occasion
ratée
israël a augmenté sa taille la première
occasion ratée sur 1937
c'était le plan pile anglais qui avait
proposé de partager de créer deux états
et israël récupérer cinq mille
kilomètres carrés de terrain ça a été
refusé par les arabes en 47 le plan de
l'onu le vote de l'onu attribué aux deux
et a attribué à israël une base de 10
mille kilomètres carrés en 48 à la suite
des attaques arabes contre israël et de
la guerre d'indépendance
israël s'est retrouvé à occuper vingt
mille kilomètres carrés dont vous et que
chaque refus entraîne en 67 après la
guerre de bon après la guerre des six
jours
eh bien on a ajouté toute la cisjordanie
à israël
et ça elle s'est retrouvée avec 26 mille
kilomètres carrés
donc chaque refus arabe entraînent la
croissance du 2
l'état d'israël donc moi ça c'est une
constatation ce n'est pas une autre
chose
moi ce que je voudrais dire aujourd'hui
c'est que on croit que cette ce plan se
partagent plan de partage de donald
trump n'est que pro israélien moi je
peux donner plusieurs exemples et
plusieurs cas pour dire qu'en fait c'est
le premier ministre netanyahu et forcé
davanier d'avaler des couleuvres
d'ailleurs je pense on va le voir demain
je pense que beaucoup de deux
politiciens de droite vont hurler au
problème à ce plan de partage je
donnerai deux cas simplement deux points
premier point jérusalem sera partagée
donald trump a dit que jérusalem sera
partagée pour les deux états israël et
la palestine
or pendant longtemps la vie et les
allées les nationalistes juifs disait
israël et indivisible ça c'est un
premier point et deuxième point nous
nous retrouvons à avoir des relations
avec des zones qui sont pas autorisés
c'est à dire qu'en fait que on va on va
pas accepter l'année
l'annexion pure et simple comme
netanyahou l'a dit trump a autorisé
simplement l'annexion de certains
territoires
or natanyahou vous les indexer la
totalité de ces territoires dont
netanyahu n'a pas gagné dans ce domaine
donc je donne simplement deux exemples
je pouvais en donner beaucoup d'autres
beaucoup d'autres
mais ceci pour dire que c'est quand même
pas une victoire totale de natanyahou ce
n'est pas une victoire totale de je
dirais de la droite c'est simplement que
ils ont fait des concessions
et dans le fond c'est pas mauvais qu'ils
fassent des concessions
on ne peut avancer que s'il ya des
concessions de part et d'autres par
contre ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
que les palestiniens refusent ce plan se
refuse ce plan et on va se retrouver à
chaque fois à une avancée de deh
d'israël qui va encore gagner du terrain
il va on va écouter on a bien compris le
message jacques benillouche on va
écouter la réponse de bernard ravenel
vous allez répondre peut-être point par
point mais alors moi c'est vrai que
j'avais une interrogation jacques
benillouche à évoquer cette histoire de
capital alors donald trump a quand même
rappelé le caractère indivisible
jérusalem la capitale indivisible
d'israël at il dit mais on évoquant dans
le même temps une capitale pour les a
pas laissés pour les palestiniens de
jérusalem-est alors c'est vrai que ça je
peux être le j'attends vos lumières sur
ce point l'un et l'autre savent quoi
concrètement et je vous laisse
effectivement répondre à jacques
benillouche qui dit à chaque fois à
chaque fois les palestiniens ont perdu
quand ils ont vu musée c'est l'analyse
en tout cas de jacques benillouche non
j'ai bien compris la situation actuelle
et la décision de l'épreuve et cetera
c'est la faute aux arabes
je voudrais quand même qu'on limite un
petit peu cette observation
parce qu'en réalité aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on obtient des ténias où il
obtient une sorte de feu vert pour
commencer continuer à conquérir la
cisjordanie
en commençant par la vallée du jourdain
c'est ça l'événement en quelque sorte
factuel aussi considérable qui va en
quelque sorte franchir une étape
à mon avis tout à fait décisive dans la
nature des conflits doivent juste pas si
on peut parler de ça mais c'est une
poursuite de la colonisation
puisqu'on veut être up a accepté de
reconnaître la légitimité des colonies
et de sacs à main phénomène même si
extraordinaire donc c'est la
continuation
la légitimation de la colonisation de
l'ensemble de la politique de fait
bombance en plus sans parler du golan
qui appartenait el achiri donc trouvé
que ce moyen et a fait des concessions
c'est absolument remarquable parce qu'en
réalité et natanyahou quelque sorte à
gagner quel est le problème derrière
roissy
c'est un problème politique que les deux
protagonistes les trains italiens ont
derrière eux c'est à dire et le problème
du netanyahu c'est de gagner gagner des
élections et titre up soutien netanyahu
dans cette perspective de la future
élection qui ont lieu en israël
c'est ça l'enjeu politique immédiat 1 et
donc de ce point de vue là je suis à
yahoo a gagné à gagner le problème
j'avais ce qui va gagner les élections
c'est un autre sujet mais enfin chacun
coûte plus tout à fait considérable et
très significatif très significatif
et quelle donc je considère que dire que
la la situation finalement fait que les
policiers auraient tort de ne pas
accepter ces plans ou d'en discuter
on est le problème c'est qu'on l'ait
jamais consulté cette question va
peut-être regarder la carte 4,8 et un
lui-même donald trump qui serait
effectivement la nouvelle carte jacques
benillouche haut sur ce point
effectivement donald trump
en gros les etats-unis qui sont frères
reconnaître la souveraineté israélienne
sur des territoires occupés mais c'est
de manière un petit peu unilatérale est
ce que on peut finalement accepté qu'un
accord comme ça soit acceptée alors
qu'ont décidé les choses de manière
unilatérale
sofia pas la commune sic perciot ya une
situation de fait il faut le dire on de
que voulez vous qu'on fasse
qu'on envoie des troupes expulser tous
les juifs 600 milles entre 500 mille six
cent mille qui sont aujourd'hui
installés dans ces territoires
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
impossible à envisager et aucun
américain
aucun israélien acceptera cette
situation donc je reviens sur ce que je
disais il faut être pragmatique
moi je pense que si des négociations
avancent il est fort probable que les
les idées de avigdor lieberman le
nationalisme pur et dur qui a mis de
l'eau dans saab autre cas je dirais et
bien ce que propose lieberman c22
d'offrir entre guillemets toute une
bande de terre où il y a une dizaine de
villages arabes israéliens qui colle la
frontière qui colle la ligne verte de
offrir toute cette terre-là pour
compenser la terre qu'ils auront pris en
cisjordanie c'est à dire qu'on donnerait
en gros un territoire arabe contre un
territoire éventuellement juifs
donc il y a des possibilités il ya des
possibilités de négociation mais on n'a
pas fini la sur ce point fait répond non
mais ça c'est le vieux projet de
la lieberman le problème c'est que
d'abord si on a consulté des populations
concernées sur la population à consulter
les représentants de ces populations et
jeu par la pression que cet effet j'ai
toujours une pratique unilatérale de
virer les les arabes d'israël pour faire
10 serait en quelque sorte un état juif
complètement et j'ose dire qu en tant qu
il met donc il ya merveille c'est que
les parisiens sont exclues de tout débat
de toute négociation alors les y
participe a bien sûr on est ce que tu es
ce que tu vas pas consulté a vu le
mahmoud abbas c est absolument avec
sardines lettres oddity d'une lettre
donc estimant que son plan était une
chance expliqué que le territoire prévu
pour son nouvel état resteraient ouverts
et sans développement de colonies
israéliennes pendant une période de
quatre ans voilà ce qu'a lit d'hôtel
trump à mahmoud abbas
aujourd'hui politiquement ce café
netanyahu at n'a jamais été pour quelque
chose
condamné par la communauté
internationale en particulier est
évident que nous tirions veut faire ce
qu'il veut parce qu'il y aura une
habilité à ce qu'il fait et donc je
crois que demain pour le gault lent donc
il ya toute cette histoire qui est
derrière
il faut pas faire croire que il y a une
perspective ouverte de paix négociée
parce que finalement le brésilien s'est
encore réduire de perdre une grande
partie encore de leur territoire reconnu
par la communauté internationale par le
droit international
donc on est plus à 22% on va diminuer
encore les pourcentages au octroyé si on
peut dire aux politiciens moi cette
carte-là méfaits passés en quelques
jeunes aux bantoustans d'afrique du sud
là quelque chose qui est on dira dirait
que les américains n'ont pas n'ont pas
appris de l'histoire de ce qui s'est
passé en afrique du sud
là quelque chose de pathétique
finalement dans cette dans cette
histoire et qui aussi est un peu
dramatique pour l'ensemble de la région
comment pouvez vous expliquer que
plusieurs pays arabes étaient présents à
la présentation du plan plusieurs pays
arabes unis et la jordanie et les
émirats et d'autres encore comment
expliquer que beaucoup de pays arabes
sont prêts à se faire le pas alors on va
dire ce sont des impérialistes on va
dire que ce sont des des gens non
démocrates
il ya quand même certains pays qui
estiment qu'il faut cesser et qu'on ne
peut pas continuer à faire la guerre
parce que la guerre n'apportera rien la
guerre n'apportera rien politiquement
aux palestiniens et la contractent des
malheurs donc je pense personnellement
et je suis comme vous un amoureux de la
paix moi je pense qu'il faut que les
gens s'asseyent sur la base d'un plan ce
plan là n'est pas définitif
ce blond et détail a été proposé aux
deux parties qui doivent maintenant
s'asseoir discuter et vous savez que
nous sommes au moyen-orient et les
marchandages marche très bien à
copenhague chantage messieurs il ya
quelque chose de très important dont on
n'a pas encore parlé dans ce plan c'est
les soi-disant un million d'emplois
vanté par donald trump 1,59 dollar dans
des territoires qui qui souffrent
économiquement bernard avanandé la paix
économique qui ne marche jamais on a on
a tenté d'aller compris la france a
tenté avec des algériens avec jeu pong
constantine paix économique en valeur
cette île c'est pas ça que veulent les
palestiniens et veulent reconnaissent
qu'on reconnaisse leurs droits c'est ça
qu'est leur dignité politique
donc je pense que c'était un leurre qui
est fin d'année et puis quand en
confirmant le soutien des états arabes à
israël
c'est pas la première fois que les états
de mariachis jack arabie saoudite
c'est pas la première fois que j'étais
arabes n'ont jamais soutenu vraiment les
palestiniens mais ça c'est un situe
malheureusement c'est le drame des
palestiniens c'est pavard été soutenue
de fait par les etarras et ça fait
partie de l'évolution de la situation
encore encore plus grave donc faire
croire qu'il est des arabes comme
soutenu ce projet est un aspect positif
on n'est pas rien pas du tout pas du
tout des populations arabes
ils étaient libres s'exprimer dans le
monde arabe refuserait c'est ce qui va
se passer d'ailleurs je pense et mais
malheureusement je ne serai pas
forcément à commencer par ce qu'il va se
passer je pense en jordanie
parce que là nous avons une situation
qui va être un petit peu délicate c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire
comment peut réagir le reste du monde
parce qu'on a déjà vu les premières
réactions londres qui parle d' avance
moscou qui appelle israël verrez pas
destiné à négocier directement l'egypte
qui appelle les israéliens dans le même
temps à d'ailleurs et palestiniens à
examiner ce plan de manière attentif et
approfondir le rôle des autres pays a
entre nîmes et va être important et
crucial à jouer
je voudrais rebondir juste une question
importante c'est la paix par l'économie
vous devez savoir qu'aujourd'hui il y à
l'équivalent de 150 mille ouvriers
palestiniens qui traversent la frontière
de cisjordanie pour venir travailler en
israël
sans ces ouvriers là il n'y aurait plus
de construction en israël il n'y aurait
plus de ramassage des légumes
il n'y aurait plus même dans certains
cas de tra de travaux de travaux publics
donc je dis que les palestiniens sont
prêts à collaborer à l'heure actuelle
les le ramasse est en négociations
secrètes avec israël via l'egypte elle
ramasse et de nos demandes
justement à ce qu'il y ait des ouvriers
palestiniens qui rentrent en israël et
on a accepté sous une forme déguisée
on a accepté qu'ils et 10000 20000 qui
serait qu'ils rentrent qui sont
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle la qui
travaillent
cela veut dire qu'il peut y avoir un
échange le la cisjordanie et gaza
c'est un vivier de main d'oeuvre israël
a beaucoup de problèmes
demandeur c'est un petit pays qui n'a
pas suffisamment demandeur et donc c'est
là on peut alors certains vont dire oui
mais on va pas contre que de l'amateur
il a aussi vous devez savoir que la
moitié des médecins en israël sont des
arabes
la moitié des pharmaciens sont des armes
aux médecins est un médecin arabe
quand je vais dans ma pharmacie c'est un
arabe qui me sert donc dire que il n'ya
il y a un problème entre les arabes et
celle je dis que c'est non et à l'heure
actuelle vous pouvez le vérifier il y à
des négociations secrètes leur hamas est
prêt à signer un accord de paix avec
israël
sa poupe à l'heure actuelle il ya
simplement à petit une petite question
qui bloque c'est une question d'une
personne le ram à s'imposer vous allez
comprendre
or là le paradoxe il le ramasse un poste
que mara que à marwan barghouti l'ancien
chef du fatah soit libéré dans un
échange de deux prisonniers
c'est quand même étonnant que le ramasse
demande à ce qu'un gars du fatah soit
libéré ça veut dire qu'on va écouter la
réponse de bernard ravenel respecter le
temps de parole
si j'ose dire les choses sont moins pire
que ce qu'on veut bien nous présenter
ici sur le terrain manifestement selon
un timing nous le problème c'est que y
compris si on veut faire la comparaison
que j'aime pas tellement avec l'afrique
du sud l'afrique du sud le régime avait
besoin de la main d'oeuvre
moi à l'époque et d'ailleurs ils étaient
autorisés à passer avec un système de
contrôle de même d'ailleurs que l'aller
les palestiniens de cisjordanie en
systèmes de contrôle assez terrible pour
patients d'israël passons mais est-ce
que je crains c'est pas ça que demandent
les les parisiens et demande à voir une
souveraineté une une fin de l'occupation
israélienne sur leur pays sur leurs
populations sur leur territoire c'est ça
et c'est ça qu'ils n'obtiennent pas un
rond contraire ça va s'aggraver donc je
pense que on détourne de sujet on
détourne le problème en quelques sortes
en ne parlant pas de la fin de
l'occupation militaire et de la cac et
le signe de la cud à la fin de la
présidence était la rutel israélienne
sur sur la palestine et qui va être
quelque chose à graver et légitime et
pas par patron donc je crois que et je
crois qu'on se trouve de débats je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la question est celle de
l'établissement d'un état palestinien
souverain autonome indépendant de toute
pression de toute souveraineté
israélienne et ça s'est refusé j'ai
refusé d'ailleurs semaine a refusé notre
manière de dire que c'est la seule
chance pour les palestiniens d'obtenir
un état indépendant vous ne croyez pas
du tout malheureusement si je pourrai y
est quoi ce serait bien parce que ce
fait des années qu'il saura par l'état
de palestine
on est on négocie même pas avec ceux qui
se croient qu'ils représentent
aujourd'hui alors faire croire que ça va
être plus tard eux-mêmes qui va être
l'état palestinien est une véritable
plaie
entrée malheureusement dramatique pour
les palestiniens nous sommes au début
d'une phase politique nouvelle
moyen-orient qui est muté caractérisée
par le fait que la question
palestinienne n'est pas résolu n'est pas
résolu et que les palestiniens vont été
obligé dans une citation de de révolte
supplémentaires faut s'attendre à des
formes de soulèvements relativement
dramatique et moi je suis très inquiet
pour ça parce que netanyahu est capable
de faire la guerre comme vous le savez
et il d'autre part puisque le hamas
semble vouloir négocier avec israël il
ya un rôle très important dans la
création d amasser très bien démontré et
la grande réussite d'israël c'est
d'avoir divisé et compris la
représentation palestinienne entre le
hamas et le fatah est que aujourd'hui
vouloir négocier séparément avec l'une
des deux parties pour empêcher justement
l'union des deux forces pour négocier en
tant que représentant de l'encens des
palestiniens
c'est effectivement un grand succès pour
israël et c'est une grande défaite pour
les spas les chiens il faut bien il faut
bien reconnaître et ça veut dire aussi
ça veut dire aussi qu'il n'y aura pas de
reconnaissance d'un état palestinien
souverain sur les 10 et sur ce qui est
prévu par le droit international
c'est-à-dire sud et 22% de la chaîne pas
les chaînes historiques
c'était ça l'enjeu la ligne verte
qu'elle veut absolument maintenant
violet de toute manière et qui va l'être
dans les jours qui viennent dans les
mois qui viennent par là par le
gouvernement israélien qui l'italien ou
est réélu très rapidement le mot de la
fin
ce qu'on arrive à la fin de ce débat
vous craignez aussi la réaction des
palestiniens que craint bernard ravenel
avec éventuellement un embrasement
je ne veux pas trahir les secrets de bep
en contre j'ai beaucoup de rencontres
avec des arabes palestiniens nous qui
traversent la frontière de temps en
temps nous rencontrons dans une ville
palestinienne de temps en temps c'est
eux qui traverse en ayant le droit de
traverser ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'ils sont tous unanimes à rechercher
cette paix quand je leur dis mais enfin
dix mois
qu'est ce qui se passe chez vous comment
se fait-il que vous n'arrivez pas à
obtenir quoi que ce soit de la part de
votre direction
il me dit mais
mahmoud abbas détient les clés détient
les clés du coffre fort sans argent nous
ne pouvons rien faire c'était comme ça
hier avec yasser arafat
aujourd'hui c'est pareil donc si jamais
on veut faire la révolution
eh bien on n'obtiendra rien c'est pour
ça que cette révolution à n'arrive pas
encore en cisjordanie mais ce qu'ils
veulent c'est avoir des bonnes relations
avec israël gagner de l'argent et avoir
une bonne solution de paix donc moi
personnellement qui ne suis pas un
va-t-en-guerre et bien j'estime que
c'est en discutant en émotions en
échangeant des idées et ne pas en sept
ans ne s'attaquant pas que nous pouvons
obtenir quelque chose
la paix par l'économie j'y crois
beaucoup et je ne suis pas le seul à y
croire
il suffit de savoir que quand un ouvrier
vient travailler en israël
il fait vivre quatre familles et c'est
pour ça que quand il ya 100 cents soit
100 à 150 milles
le travailleur qui rendre en israël ces
six cent mille familles qui vivent grâce
à israël
et ce sont des gens que je côtoie tous
les jours dans la rue parce que chez
nous il y à des travaux partout là dans
ma résidence des gens construisent des
balcons je les vois je discute avec eux
ils savent ne sachant à l'ancien ancien
en tunisie dont je dirais connaissant
les arabes
eh bien ils acceptent de parler avec moi
et ils disent la vérité
ils disent malheureusement nous n'avons
pas de bons dirigeants mais nous nous
sommes prêts nous venons nous
travaillons ici et nous ne ferons rien
pour nous qu'on pourquoi nous empêche de
rentrer en israël et donner de l'argent
et donner de la nourriture à nos enfants
qui est certains disent même
nous voulons qu'ils aillent à
l'université israélienne
parce que pour nous c'est le meilleur
moyen de pouvoir créer un état libre
merci c'est la loose merci ça sera pour
vous le mot de la fin qu'il est petit
conclusions sur ce panneau à paris
mais je dirais deux deux phrases on peut
dire l'histoire de la décolonisation
monde qu'on n'a jamais gagné la paix en
faisant quelque sorte une oeuvre un
aspect économique qui sans régler la
question politique de la d'indépendance
des peuples colonisés
deuxièmement je crois que la défaillance
maintenant des états unis pour faire
respecter le droit international et donc
les droits compris des palestiniens
oblige maintenant l'union européenne n'a
pas répondu pour maintenant je pense que
maintenant c'est l'union européenne
d'avoir une initiative est coupé pour
une conférence internationale qui serait
réunie et qui serait fondée sur la
question du droit international en
liaison avec l'onu je pense que pas
d'autres perspectives
aujourd'hui et je vois qu'il craque
minnillo chaleur remet çà mau je dis
simplement que l'europe est absente et
je leur en fait ce que lui reproche et
je le regrette et je regrette que la
sorte que la france soit absente et je
regrette que la france n'est pas un rôle
de d'arbitrage
je fais tout avec les ambassadeurs comme
je les rencontre je leur dit toujours
cela la france doit intervenir comme
comme arbitre et la france et si on a
compris mais elles deviennent recentrer
leur but
merci en tout cas tous les deux pour ce
débat nourri rabanel jacques benillouche
à tel aviv merci à vous deux on se
retrouve dans